Pennsylvania Republican congressman Tim
Murphy says he will not seek re-election
after reports he asked his mistress to
have an abortion
the lawmaker who has opposed abortion
said in a statement he is taking time
quote to seek health as my family and I
continue to work through our personal
difficulties the announcement comes just
one day after the Pittsburgh
post-gazette published apparent text
messages between representative Murphy
and his alleged mistress Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning the final straw appears to have
been a newly published memo in which
Murphy's top staffer here on Capitol
Hill
reportedly accuses him of fostering an
abusive workplace environment but even
before that he was fending off
accusations of hypocrisy over his public
and private stances on abortion it is
not just some amorphous cells there
floating about but these are real beings
for more than a decade on Capitol Hill
Pennsylvania congressman Tim Murphy has
backed up pro-life agenda and we have
every right to protect those lives as
part of our responsibility as men and
his father's but according to the
Pittsburgh post-gazette in January
Murphy's alleged mistress shannon
edwards texted him saying you have zero
issue posting your pro-life stance all
over the place when you had no issue
asking me to abort our unborn child just
last week murphy reportedly responded i
get what you say about my march for life
messages i've never written them staff
does them the story unfolded just as the
House approved legislation Tuesday that
would make abortions after 20 weeks
illegal Murphy a member of the House
pro-life caucus co-sponsored and voted
for the bill the Post Gazette also
obtained a memo reportedly written by
Murphy's chief of staff in June that
claims staffers have been exposed to
angry aggressive and abusive behavior
from the congressman which has led to a
nearly 100 percent turnover within one
year's time on a recent visit to his
home district she writes your driving
was dangerous and erratic I feared for
my life I repeatedly at least 15
I asked you to stop texting Murphy's
hostility and insults she adds her
frightening Murphy's ex mistresses
pregnancy scare turned out to be a false
alarm and he has made his decision now
to retire after meeting with House
Speaker Paul Ryan but he says Gail he
will serve out his remaining 15 months
in office all right Thank You Nancy